zack snyder's army of the dead has
already provided an embarrassment of
riches by the time his third act rolls
around
from zombie tigers to speed ramp
slaughter to tygnotaro rocking a swisher
sweet
and then just when you think there are
no more surprises in store a miracle of
life occurs
or more accurately a miracle of
zombified undeath
army of the dead introduces a fresh take
on the shambling corpses that we all
know and love
namely the movies alpha zombies who are
faster
stronger and more intelligent than their
lesser brothers and sisters
the alphas are the de facto main
antagonists in this new and dead world
with snyder recently describing them as
zombies that have taken another step
suitably then these highly adaptable
creatures are seen getting up to all
kinds of shenanigans
including a few you might not expect
from the ordinary undead
case in point after the beheading of the
alpha's queen her drooly boo
zeus takes her lifeless body somewhere
private
zeus then mournfully roots around in his
beloved's torso with his other zombie
pals close by
presumably for moral support but just
what is that why the old zombie looking
for in the guts of his one and only
why a luminescent blue bundle of undead
fetus of course
which he gently cradles in two cupped
desiccated hands
and well that certainly answers one
question it also raises so many more
here's the big one though where do
zombie babies come from
there's not really a delicate way to put
this but it may have more than a little
bit to do with zombie mommy and zombie
daddy loving each other very much
at least that's what zack snyder had in
mind when he introduced the idea of
zombie children
to his latest movie in a recent
interview with esquire snyder was asked
the big question
how are zombie babies made ever the
detail-oriented director snyder replied
well i believe that some zombie love
happened some sweet zombie lovemaking
then in what can only be described as
the world's fastest retcon he added i
don't know if it was sweet it was
probably
pretty aggressive snyder continued my
theory is that the zombies in our movie
are working toward not needing a human
host to procreate their species if you
will
that's the ultimate evolution and if
that still seems a little vague for your
liking
fear not because esquire's interviewer
knows what we all need to know
when they straighten her past whether
the zombies and army of the dead
like to get busy snyder replied yeah
unfortunately we don't see
that but yes i think theoretically they
do
and just like that movie fans around the
globe found themselves wondering if zack
snyder really knows what the word
unfortunately means but hey there's some
good news here for the walking dead
themselves
after all children are often seen as an
opportunity for new parents to undergo a
little self-reflection
and even become better people maybe the
ability to procreate could afford these
zombies a chance to really think about
what they want from life
maybe they could change their eating
habits or consider finding employment in
a field
that doesn't involve groaning and
chewing on people maybe they can even
learn to love
i don't see nothing wrong with it but i
know that some people would see
something wrong with it but it's my
husband you know
i still love him i've still got the ring
on my finger trisha
probably not though still one thing is
for sure the zombie baby and army of the
dead
isn't actually hollywood's first
go-round with undead infants
however things don't really go smoothly
when a movie chooses to introduce the
spawn of the dead
for example in his pre-hobbit days peter
jackson made the deeply weird
dead alive which featured a truly
disturbing zombie baby
this isn't even the first time that zack
snyder has plugged a zombie baby into
his work
2004's dawn of the dead the director's
feature film debut
also featured a short-lived zombie tyke
but that one doesn't exactly turn out
great either
so what do you think about all this
zombie baby business
maybe we should just chalk this all up
as a failed experiment and let the
zombies get back to eating people's
brains
rather than each other's faces check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one